the first thing we're going to do is we
need to do a little bit of setup
because this thing at the moment is um
well it's not set up the way we need it
to be for the amount of topics that
we've done and the way we're going to
compare this okay
so the first thing i want you to do is
come up to um this
wrench in the top right corner which has
settings i'm going to hit projector mode
you don't need to do that
but what you do need to do i mean you
can it would just look really
bold everything will look really bold
what i do want to do is hit degrees
we will get to radians later on but for
now degrees
and then when you can see axes right can
you see axes we're going to
change the domain and range that are
viewable
on the screen okay so if you click on
the domain
right there for instance you might put
-360
to 360. right you can edit that there
and then on the y-axis we're going to be
looking at trig graphs so can i have a
suggestion
as to what range should be there minus
one to one
okay so now the graph should be adjusted
and you can see what you've got there
okay now if i
pull this back a little bit because it's
grouping
which things like you know these are
like negative 360
360. oh well that's going to be it's
just two spots there's just two numbers
there
now you'll notice mine has changed and
so will yours if you zoom in or out
i've zoomed out a little bit so now it's
gone minus 720 to 720 but
you can zoom in and out and change
however you like okay
now you'll see periodically this part on
the left hand side
i'm going to hide that every now and
then because um
that way you can see the whole thing
because on the screen you don't get the
whole view you probably don't need to do
that but it's up to you
so what we're going to start with is
sine
so if you just put in sine x there okay
you'll notice mine looks a whole lot
thicker than yours and like i said
that's because i have projector mode
highlighted if you want to make it look
like someone's gone over everything with
a highlighter
be my guest but i'm just gonna do it so
it's really clear for you guys and it'll
come up on the um
on the recording so there's sign x right
now
i have got the page number now 127 127
there are a bunch of trigonometric
ratios there that have been adjusted
there are minus signs and there are
shifts and we're going to investigate
them okay
so here's the way i'm going to do this
if you just typed in sine x if you hit
enter it'll prompt you to put a new
graph in
okay so this is the graph i'd like you
to put in with me
it starts off the same sign open some
brackets
and i could write in i mean the first
one there is 90
plus theta so that's the same as theta
plus 90. so i could write
x plus 90 right and you can see it
graphs it for you
however this thing is rather more
powerful than that so instead of hitting
enter now
i'm going to take away the 90 and you
saw me do this before
i'm just going to put in the number a
okay so it recognizes you want to put in
a variable here
and um so that's why it hasn't grafted
yet and i'm now going to add a slider
there's that blue button there okay
bam do you see that come up yes good
okay
now this slider you can see at the
moment don't touch it yet
i've already touched it oh no i want to
muck around with it just a little bit
more before we
change it you can see it goes from -10
to 10 and
currently it's on one that's not that
useful to us at the moment so what i
want you to do is
press the number that minus 10 to 10 hit
either of those and up will come
a um a domain modifier just like we had
for the whole graph
right so you can do anything you like
but i'm going to go from 0
to 360. i'm in degrees all right
now the step if you leave that blank
then as you move
the slider back and forth it will go
down however fine
you know like point one of a degree or
something like that i
only want a certain number of them so
i'm going to make the step 15
okay because all of the interesting
angles like with exact values that we
are aware of
they're all multiples of 15 okay so i'm
going to hit enter
what you should see is now the slider
goes from as you expected not to 360
and if you squint really hard you'll see
some little white dots there
on the slider which indicate the values
that it can take
all right so now before i start to move
it
what's going to happen as i increase the
value of
a remember i've got sine of x plus a
yeah right now okay there's going to be
a shift now
this time i will do this by hand because
horizontal and vertical shifts are
notoriously confusing
concept all the way up until in the
extension two course a major part of um
a major topic is graphing okay and
people always get confused
plus is is it left or right which way is
it okay
so i always like to default back to
something i know
right so if i graph a parabola
it passes through the origin okay now
the great thing about parabolas is that
we know them
really really well you've been using
them for years okay so
if i now say to you well what about this
you know enough about this that without
too much mental strain
you can picture this without me drawing
it right i think you can just imagine
where it's going to be
has it moved to the left or to the right
it's moved to the right and you can be
certain it's moved to the right because
it has an x-intercept
of one which is to the right so there's
one
and then you draw it in no problems
okay so i always every time when i'm
like which way does it go
right i always refer back to an example
that i know
might still move it to the right so
clearly
plus we'll move it to the left
okay so now i'm expecting as i increase
this value of
a it's going to move well you can see
the colors that you should have the
original graph
is red the other graph is blue they're
currently on top of each other
but as i increase a what happens
it's moving to the left as you expected
and you can move it back
and forth or if you really want you can
hit play and it'll
step along without you touching it look
man no hands
okay so i'm going to pause it so now
let's bring it back to zero
so here's here's the point of what
they're looking at the question says
right as a trigonometric ratio of theta
so just going to call it x it's just a
variable doesn't matter
with the correct sign attached they want
us to interpret
what is sine oh i'm just going to change
it into an x
x plus 90 degrees okay they've got theta
instead of x and they have the 90
degrees back to front but it's the same
thing
okay so let's make a 90 degrees
there you go okay
so now have a look at what you've got
there
this shifted graph is the blue graph
right and the red graph is the original
okay so what's happened
what's this thing actually equal to
what's the blue graph
it's cos isn't it this is cos x
right and we looked at this every time
we were graphing right we said look this
side and causes the same thing
it's just been shifted along 90 degrees